hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play Skyrim okay I went in and
turn the brightness up but it was
already at maximum before which is like
very strange considering awfully dark
and I'm just getting some eggs
oh there's a body no disco alright
anyway moving on still looking for the
Horn of gym and Chewbacca Jumanji
what was the point of coming in here if
there's no way out
what really really really what the hell
what the hell
hello fire fire Lydia you're standing
Lydia really Lydia Lydia you're right in
the fire like literally you couldn't be
more in the fire than you are now lyddie
I've been hi Lydia
Lydia are you okay there are you okay
are you okay doing okay there you wanna
you wanna move off the fire all right no
you're usually good oh wait what
nope still not off the fire
that is phenomenal Lydia good job there
Hamm straight
okay there's nothing here oh you're
serious oh okay
spider weapon I can't see a ding dong
damn thing which is so weird why can't I
see a damn thing
that's where it was not this dirt Lydia
whatever okay
you're okay walk it off champ whoa oh
there you are
good good good job good job pisaq you
seem to be doing better now don't care I
have I've seen many things like this
born of Jumanji dark serious note I need
to speak with you to you urgently rent
the attic room at the sleeping giant
inland River wood and I'll meet you
there
I'll meet a friend screw you you're not
my friend
ya dick could you took the horn up
jermonta bay
dead bodies instead of coming here and
killing them but why didn't they kill
everything at the entrance if they were
gonna kill these calm they make me do
all the work again Borden no reward
again they're like a flashlight I could
have to them first brightening dark
empty chasse RV good thing
gimme gimme gimme ooh worth a lot
ank-ooo all the gold just kind of
inconvenient the biggest gold on the
breath Wallace garnets anymore okay
nothing else
come on Lydia what you're gonna run into
any more fire God lay this big crap oh I
swear Lydia you got issues
okay I'm gonna head it out now I need to
go for meet a friend somewhere I don't
good chunk hello just gimmie anything in
here yeah I bet none of the nothing else
is gonna have gems but I'm gonna be
forced to search in everyone because one
had a temper for give me that all right
that's okay I'll get out of here
hello how do I get out of here okay this
is the entrance okay all right this way
I go up here there's the naked person
that I made naked and then I go out here
and then I'm on my way to somewhere
where I don't know Skyrim
that's where I'm going I need to level
up okay no more
he'll always more help nothing better
than health I got one point
[Music]
yes let's finally get deep into the deep
wounds yes now there we go now we got
that taken care of we don't have the
horn but we got a note that'll lead us
to the horn let's see here
ah meet whoever took the horn back
travelled a river would things always
seem to come back to river would Lisa
never gonna get the game here cashy what
an ugly race us up right here yeah it is
it's like really bright here but down in
the dungeons I can't see a ding dong can
thing it don't matter
here you I need a selfie whatever you
see your diamond that's already mine
don't care
shut up don't make me boo you don't make
me boo you miss
who's drunk okay here we go
what have you got for sale lates helmets
yeah shut up I got anything to suit I
don't care what you have for sale I'm
selling you I guess I don't need to sell
that stuff just yet steel arrow another
it's weighing me down right what
no I clicked on the apparel pretty much
anything to suit your needs
uh uh take that why can't I sell the
magic stuff I take it I shut up all
right
what I don't have a stealing it damn it
settle me a stealing it [ __ ] why
can't I pay you don't rush today my head
like a walnut
what like a walnut crushing walnuts
between your thighs looking to protect
yourself or do some damage neither give
me one of these thank you
thank you fine sir now Depa thing that's
not very much of an increase I guess I'm
not very good at blacksmithing so
all right I guess it'll do for now
listen does I need leather to upgrade my
armor or what get out of here I don't
care if it's yours
get out Mike yeah I need more steel a
screw it it's it's not that much of an
increase at the moment hey let me see if
I can make some iron daggers get my
smithing up a bit no nope can't make
yeah uh scooping just crap no get off of
it I'm mine my iron dagger that's like
the that's what I need leather strips
hmm yeah yeah give me leather strips get
those yeah yeah I'm pressing enter iost
I know there was a way to scream okay
there we go there's a way to spin it oh
oh oh oh I don't know if you guys saw
that but it's like flashing yellow oh
yeah that's not much
I need like ten the jillion daggers
whatever whatever though it don't even
matter
I'm not the beefiest Argonian yet by the
end of this game I will be so much to us
oh yeah thank you
you're a bit of this shut up I don't
care
weapons you take these stabs just sell
them to me for the max value but I gonna
take up nothing less
Black Mage rogues those front right out
of money
necromancy robes and I can go yeah your
goal can i buy anything for you probably
not yeah look at this you're such an ass
until next time oh wait potion you and
me take a look shut up I don't care
about you and me
minor Mariner gets it dude
but I'm selling you something right back
thank take
one of these yeah take that
mm-hmm indeed now we are headed to where
are we headed
Oh in there okay there we go oops our
now we're all right now
sleeping giant in what are they doing it
here I know I'm the innkeeper oh yeah
attic room eh yeah well we don't have an
attic room but you can have the one on
the left
make yourself at home ah Jonah or
Stormcloaks God sing well impress me
steal we will take that but I shut you
up
God beckons everyone yeah yeah keep
talking guys ah yeah you done our hopes
and our dreams
shut up your son
oh that one okay
steal from chess sleep in bed do I sleep
here not tired
so you're the bargain boring oh oh oh
it's you
oh I think you're looking for this Bob
to talk or no Furyk it'd win color that
was wasn't the horn if don't rung the
guard okay all right
so you took you're telling me that you
you killed all those zombies this in key
give me a mug of ale shut up [ __ ]
right up I'll give you a mug of fist I
need some more you close the door shut
up you've had more than enough close the
sides you still haven't paid for the
last one now we can 12 oh hello and so
bad
shut up out there with your idiot okay
hello Lydia you're not supposed to be
here this secret meeting
get out of here Lydia look at the
Dragonborn the Greybeards seem to think
you're the Dragonborn uh-huh I hope
they're right they are you doubt me
you're the prize I guess I'm getting
pretty good at my harmless innkeeper Act
uh-huh I still think you're harmless ha
ha ha ha I was expecting someone taller
good the whole point of being in hiding
is to appear to be someone you're always
trouble on a whim uh uh I needed to make
sure it wasn't a foul more trap damn
foul more or enemy I already gave you
the whole believe you actually trying to
help don't trust you I just need you to
hear me out jobs out there I don't give
a frak ok you better start explaining
I'll explain what I want when I want
y'all oh don't be sad right whatever but
I knew if the rumors about you were true
yes shut up I'm part of a group that's
been looking for you mm-hmm well someone
like you for a very long time uh
whatever if you really are Dragonborn
that is I am before I tell you any more
I need to make sure I can trust you
uh-huh yeah how do I don't trust you you
were a fool to walk in here in the first
Oh oh yeah with my sword I knew the
Greybeards would send you if they
thought you were dragged when you showed
up here I knew you were the one the
Greybeards sent and not some thumb or
plant how did you knew yes enemies and
if my suspicions are correct they might
have something to do with the Dragons oh
yeah sure whatever use important right
now a reason is that you might be
Dragonborn well I guess any talk of me
is pretty important we remember what
most don't do that the Dragonborn is the
ultimate dragon slayer yeah you got that
right there only one that can kill a
dragon permanently by devouring its soul
uh-huh yeah can you do it can you devour
a dragon soul oh yeah I can
yeah and you'll have a chance to prove
it to me soon enough okay so what's the
part you're not telling us coming back
they're coming back to life
they weren't gone somewhere for all
these years they were dead centuries ago
by my predecessor aha
now something's happening to bring them
back to life wouldn't the masked dragon
stop you stolen their souls do you know
how crazy this town years ago I said
almost the same thing to a colleague of
mine well it turned out he was right and
I was wrong are you still wrong I know
they are I visited their ancient bear
and I figured out where the next one
will come we're going no and you're
going to kill that dragon yes I am but
not because you want me to I'll tell you
anything you want to know okay so where
are we at Hines Grove there's an ancient
dragon to my traveling gear all right
whatever I don't care
I'll be ready I steal your stuff here
stealing doesn't say steal oh you dress
fast I didn't even see you get naked
feeling I'm stealing all your crap all
of it all of it is mine now all of it
every little bit of it all of these and
these arrows these are mine - this is
mine as well you can keep those swords
but I'll take this this gold that okay
and this scroll that's worth five
hundred gold you okay with that lady
what about this book okay anyway that's
all the time I got for this a Habitrail
thank you guys so much for watching and
as always I'll see you in the next one
you just find that lying around it must
be your lucky you didn't see [ __ ] hey
that's all the time I got for this
episode thank you guys so much for
watching and as always see you in the
next part bye-bye